they walked and talked and talked a bit
more even enjoyed traditional dance
performances for the summit between
India's Prime Minister and China's
president had lots of photo
opportunities but no announcements of
major achievements Narendra Modi and Xi
Jinping had what was called an informal
two-day summit in the town of
mamallapuram nothing was publicly
announced on their festering border
disputes an India's foreign secretary
categorically ruled out any discussion
about the emergency in
indian-administered Kashmir following
India's removal of its autonomy he did
say India made some headway on reducing
its 51 billion dollar trade imbalance
with China obviously when such issues
are discussed at leadership level the
leadership does not go into details
it sets the direction and it has in this
case not merely set a direction it has
also decided to establish a mechanism at
high level to talk of how we can balance
trade Indian officials say the summit
has allowed the two leaders to build a
personal rapport which should enable
them to resolve their many disagreements
that may happen or not some economists
say instead of waiting for China to
bridge that trade deficit India should
instead improve its economy and load
those companies who fear the impact of
the ongoing trade war between China and
the United States 30 year old rod Shekar
is hunting for a new job
he used to assemble smartphone's in a
factory near Chennai but as Nokia users
switched to Apple iPhones Raj Shekar and
many others in the factory were made
redundant recently Raj Shekar has found
a reason to be hopeful a Taiwanese
company that assembles phones for apple
says it will start manufacturing in
India soon Apple is coming I should be
the first person they hire experience
there's no black and white some
economists say the Indian government's
decision to reduce corporate tax should
attract foreign companies and investors
there is no other country in the world
actually I would say
which can be a bass major shift from
China to India and that is the size of
the market
Prime Minister Modi aimed to woo the
Chinese leader but experts say he first
needs to launch a range of reforms and
boost economic growth before India can
really compete with world's
second-biggest economy in China
Archer Bora al-jazeera mamallapuram
India